[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I am old enough to remember
the high watermark of the Trump
presidency
can you cast your memory back that far
to the speech the one to the joint
session of Congress the ones so measured
so majestic so devoid of pants pooping
that it prompted a conservative
television pundit to say I feel like
tonight he became the president of the
United States and it prompted a liberal
television pundit to say he became the
president of the United States in that
moment period remember all the way back
to that that was a week ago that was
last Tuesday
that speech has not aged well
Tuesday 48 words in recent threats
targeting Jewish community centers and
vandalism of Jewish cemeteries remind us
that we are a country that stands United
in condemning hate and evil in all its
forms Tuesday Tuesday same day Trump
implied to a meeting of state attorneys
general according to the one from
Pennsylvania that such anti-semitic
attacks might be false flags Josh
Shapiro quoted Trump is saying sometimes
it's the reverse to make people or to
make others look bad and he used the
word reverse I would say 2 to 3 times in
his comments condemning hate the next
monday another anti-muslim travel ban
Tuesday dying industries will come
roaring back to life heroic veterans
will get the care they so desperately
need Tuesday Friday the Trump regime
deported Clarissa arredondo back to
Mexico more than two weeks after
unmarked SUV showed up at her home near
San Diego on Valentine's Day and
captured her Mazzara Dondo is the
mother-in-law of a heroic Navy veteran
now working as a contractor in
Afghanistan and the other grandmother of
that heroic veterans two toddlers he's
on active service with the army and she
may now have to retire and become a
veteran to take over the deported
and mothers role helping raise the vets
kids
what made ms Arredondo so dangerous so
needing to be urgently thrown out of
here she may have once falsified
paperwork to get her family a welfare
check Tuesday we have cleared the way
for the construction of the Keystone and
Dakota access pipelines thereby creating
tens of thousands of jobs and I've
issued a new directive that new American
pipelines be made with American steel
Tuesday Thursday quoting Fox News the
Keystone XL oil pipeline won't use u.s.
steel despite trump pledge turns out
Trump wanted you to think he meant the
Keystone would use American steel when
the truth was his executive order is
only for the next new American pipelines
because Republicans in the Senate voted
down an amendment requiring American
steel in the Keystone an amendment
proposed by Democrat Al Franken Tuesday
we will soon begin the construction of a
great wall along our southern border it
will be started ahead of schedule
Tuesday Thursday Reuters discovers that
trumps promise to use existing funds to
begin the construction has one problem
the only existing funds the Trump regime
has been able to find is 20 million
dollars 20 million dollars will build
you a Mexican wall that is less than
four miles long Tuesday Trump says his
government will be guided by two core
principles by American and higher
American Tuesday also Tuesday Ivanka
Trump tweets a photo of herself in the
dress she wore to that speech it is
identified by experts as having been
designed by a Frenchman and having been
manufactured in the United Kingdom by
American hire American Tuesday I have
ordered the Department of Homeland
Security to create an office to serve
American victims the office is called
voice victims of immigration crime
engagement we are providing a voice to
those who have been ignored by our media
and silenced by special interests
Tuesday Wednesday countless writers and
commentators note that before taking
power in Germany the
Nazis published a feature called
letterbox in their official newspaper
which provided a voice to those who had
been ignored by the media and silenced
by special interests and had been the
victims of crimes by Jews once in office
the Nazi government began publicly
disseminating the details of crimes by
Jews Tuesday we're blessed to be joined
tonight by Karen Owens the widow of a US
Navy special operator senior Chief
William Ryan Owens Ryan is looking down
right now and he's very happy because I
think he just broke a record even though
it had been Trump who gave the order
that sent chief Owens to his death in a
raid that the previous president did not
approve in an operation so controversial
that Owens father has demanded a formal
investigation even all that pundits
particularly on television fell all over
each other to praise Trump I feel like
tonight said Chris Wallace on Fox he
became the president of the United
States and everyone is gonna have to
accept that fact that was one of the
most extraordinary moments you have ever
seen in American politics period said
Van Jones until that moment a liberal on
CNN for people who have been hoping that
maybe he would remain a divisive cartoon
which he often finds a way to do they
should begin to become a little bit
worried tonight he did something tonight
that you cannot take away from him he
became President of the United States in
that moment period Tuesday in sight that
would last a lunch time not a divisive
cartoon became president have to accept
that fact Saturday terrible just found
out that Obama had my wires tapped in
Trump Tower just before the victory
nothing pound this is McCarthyism how
low as President Obama donned attacked
my phone during the very sacred election
process this is Nixon Watergate bad or
sick guy no not not a divisive cartoon
as I said this speech has not aged well
Tuesday my job is not to represent the
world my job is to represent the United
States of America Tuesday Thursday
Trump's Attorney General is forced to
recuse himself from any investigations
of the Trump presidential campaigns
interactions with
Russia because at best he personally
failed to reveal his interactions with
Russia while part of the campaign at a
meeting he got to by spending campaign
money
Tuesday we can only get there together
we are one people with one destiny we
all bleed the same blood we all salute
the same flag and we're all made by the
same God Tuesday Thursday a facebook and
tweet storm about Jeff Sessions and
about the nearly 66 million people who
voted for the Democratic candidate this
whole narrative is a way of saving face
for Democrats losing an election that
everyone thought they were supposed to
win but Democrats are over playing their
hand they lost the election and now they
have lost their grip on reality we can
only get there together we all salute
the same flag we're all made by the same
God except you 66 million people who
voted for Hillary Tuesday the time for
small thinking is over the time for
trivial fights is behind us
Tuesday Saturday Arnold Schwarzenegger
isn't voluntarily leaving The Apprentice
he was fired by his bad pathetic ratings
not by me sad end to great show the time
for small thinking is over the man is
not going to change the man is not going
to improve the man is not going to be
cured the man is not going to become
presidential the man is not going to
devote himself to anything except his
own extraordinary irrational
unquenchable insatiable unslaked Bowl
immeasurable bottomless endless eternal
need to keep Trump first and to make his
ego great again resist peace